juste derrière moi derrière le fleuve
Nièvre les territoires
occupés par la Russie à 4 km à vol
d'oiseau à peine mais nous nous trouvons
ici à Mirail tout petit village pris par
l'armée russe ou tout début de
l'invasion et repris par les troupes
sucréniennes le 2 octobre dernier dans
cette paisible commune épargnée par les
bombes pendant 7 mois difficile de se
figurer les stigmates de la guerre une
semaine après la Libération pourtant un
missile russe s'est abattu sur le jardin
de l'école aucune victime mais toutes
les fenêtres ont explosées pas de quoi
impressionner le directeur qui aide
lui-même à réparer les dégâts tout le
monde s'active certains mettent leur
véhicule à disposition chacun fait ce
qu'il peut on élimine une par une les
conséquences de cette attaque de missile
aujourd'hui comme pendant l'occupation
les habitants s'entraident Marina est
infirmière à domicile depuis plus de 20
ans elle aurait pu quitter le village en
mars dernier
mais elle est restée pour soigner les
villageoises immobilisés comme cet homme
souffrant d'un ulcère ou simplement pour
apporter un soutien moral aux habitants
entre 40 et 50 personnes par jour peu
importe leur problème certains ont des
névroses certains de l’hypertension vous
savez il y a aussi des gens seuls sans
enfant ayant perdu leur femme ou leur
mari qui viennent juste me voir pendant
l'occupation Valentina aussi a souhaité
se rendre utile elle nous amène dans une
petite fabrique fermée depuis 10 ans
qu'elle a refait fonctionner pour une
occasion toute particulière
avec d'autres habitants cette ancienne
boulangère s'est remise à faire du pain
mais aussi des pâtes alors que le
village avait des difficultés à
s'approvisionner remise en état des
machines farines fournies par des
paysans
un système D pour une vente a pris
coûtant l'unique récompense la gratitude
des habitants
on est arrivé un matin et un petit mot
écrit par les villageois nous
attendaient sur la porte
on peut notamment y lire merci pour le
pain quotidien en cette période
difficile
la dernière fournée date du début du
mois à l'arrivée des troupes
ukrainiennes depuis Valentina a
raccroché son tablier tandis que le
drapeau bleu et jaune lui flotte à
nouveau sur Mireille lifeca
le royaume